so I my buddy was the strike force
champion who uh Nate Marquardt yep and I
watched Nate um
a little out of term but I have a great
deal of respect for Nate marquard he was
just one of the great Fighters and I
watched Nate
sort of they were calling him a knockout
artist
and I watched this guy who would just
get in there and fight and react to
whatever was given to him I watched him
start trying to be enough
yeah I'm in no position to tell MMA
fighter how to fight but I do know
performance psychology yeah and I
noticed he was doing a lot of interviews
and I had a conversation with him and I
said you you cannot listen to anybody
tell you you're a [ __ ] knockout
artist because then you're gonna
understand anybody tell you you're
anything about how you fight because if
you listen to that you are going to try
to fulfill that [ __ ] yeah that becomes
your brand
[ __ ] off yeah don't listen you have to
you react to what you're given and
fighting is a beautiful example of that
in real time right yeah it's like
kinetic chess
and so I I I'm so he said can you come
and talk to tough The Ultimate Fighter
about performance like because it helped
me so he brought me to Vegas and I walk
in and Shane Carwin's there and welcome
dude and I and this guy named Brennan
Shaw who of course I'd seen fight was
there but I'm now I walk in I [ __ ]
I've got like a Blazer on and not these
I'm it's like a gazelle and a lion's den
yeah I start producing estrogen
immediately yeah just like what the [ __ ]
am I doing here and I and I I realize I
go I have to talk to these guys about
and I did a little bit and I ended up
just being funny and [ __ ] around and
then they came to my show that night and
I'm [ __ ] so funny
man tears guys seriously and um and they
[ __ ] shop and I and Shop moved to
Marina del Rey and then we just started
hanging out oh really and then I said to
him I go bro and then me and Rogan were
at metamoros with him and he was making
us laugh he was telling us what's
metamoras
Jiu-Jitsu thing and he was making us
laugh tell us Rogan's cackling he didn't
know him and I and he goes dude that
guy's [ __ ] funny and I go yeah no I
don't hang with him because he's got big
muscles yeah yeah I mean I do sort of
but yeah yeah but you know for the most
part he was [ __ ] hilarious and I said
to him I go let's do a podcast together
and we'll talk about fighting and he
said no we're not going to do talk about
fighting let's talk about life and
that's how fighter and the kid really
now he was the fighter and the kid so
why did you guys do that title I came up
with the title because I came to set one
day when I was doing a movie yeah with
Jane Lynch and I and I looked at
everyone and I go guys
um please refer to me as the kid from
now on uh say kid and I'd go please call
me the kid okay I thought he was a fight
they were like why and I said I gave
myself that nickname from 40 year old
version yeah I was not that that silly
movie no but it was the one before that
but thank you for asking I went from The
Hangover to those two movies I made a
lot of good choices yeah Joker Joker if
you if you blink you see that much in my
face oh the UFC movie what's the UFC
Warrior Warrior I put the wrong director
together for that movie you were talking
wild [ __ ] about Tom Hardy
I like Tom
but when I did uh [ __ ] um oh joker
I'm there for like four days with career
Barnes yeah
I've been doing this so long we're doing
it and Joaquin Phoenix is there and he's
in the room the whole time never said
Higher by once because he's so in
[ __ ] yeah yeah character all right
whatever is he what is that called
method method method yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah imagine not Izzy method
though oh like like big time like he
they he was 184 pounds and and Todd
Phillips said yeah something effective I
think he should be skinny yeah and so
this [ __ ]
I think came to set at 126 pounds wow
this [ __ ] apparently he didn't
want to apparently Todd Phillips was
like you need to be this skinny and he
was like no that's too much Todd's not
like that Todd will say Todd is Todd's
beautiful because Todd is really good at
fig he doesn't he allows you a lot of
leeway but he knows exactly what he
wants but he's not going to do it he'll
just say I think he might be skinnier
you know because it was it was really
about an incel that was the idea and so
he he and so Joaquin Phoenix who's got
this inhuman discipline they said we'll
get you a nutritionist and he was like
no [ __ ] off I'll eat an apple a day and
just smoke I'm not kidding and I saw
this [ __ ] when I got to set and
I said hey this time he was doing the
scene in the bus where he can't stop
laughing yeah yeah yeah that scene is
amazing now I watched that dude I
watched one [ __ ] frame one frame like
that and I and I looked at how I go he's
gonna win an Oscar really it was like
the fighter when you saw Christian Bale
yeah my student and I was like this
[ __ ] is going to win the minute
opening frame I went oh oh oh oh oh no
this is crazy oh he's gonna win I
thought that was great I rewatched it
like a week ago and I was like yo
Fighter the fighter phenomenal right I
still don't think it holds a candle to
well I'd never seen anything like Joe so
here's the big secret too so Joaquin
they went
hmm I don't know if I can well I bet I
believe that there were other actors on
that list
to play Joker interesting and and
everybody was afraid of that role
everybody who's a great actor is afraid
of that who do you think there's so much
for error who do you think stop that
lyrics
my third best student turned it down did
you deserve it huh did you deserve that
role did they come to me first
no
the person that's number one in
Hollywood that you would go to First no
matter what Leo yeah yeah that would
always be the guy so it starts I'm not
saying that's true I'm not I'm not you
just assume most lists start at Leo Duff
yeah the top three was always Leo Brad
Pitt Will Smith there you go that was
the thing now now Will Smith's Joker
would be hilarious I'd love to see that
yeah you know who could be a good Joker
Jada
[Laughter]
and I like her with that shaved head I
think she's hot as [ __ ] I mean just are
you just trying not to get slapped right
now or what's what's going on